so but Jesus was never about eye for an
eye or oh okay so so Jesus's Ministry
basically this is another thing this is
a good point that you're making Yeah so
basically Jesus ministry he was at the
time of the the rabbis who was basically
taken the wealth of the people using
their position right okay and they had
manipulated the law to use their
position so the Pharisees right the
Pharisees okay so these are the ones
that talked about this is what uh Jesus
he he cast out the money lenders in the
temple right okay
there's a tradition the corruption
happened much earlier with Moses where
these these Pharisees they invented laws
that such as the Priestly gifts where it
was basically the levite sort of the
chosen people and we have to have the
best cuts of meat so they emphasize the
law for them and they said that this law
is from God so if they added to this law
when you look back at the Old Testament
and the New Testament you can see this
as well Jesus is when when he crossed
out the the people when you look back
you can see that there's an emphasis on
the priests the descendants of Aaron the
Levites they have to have the best
positions they have to have the best
cuts of me yeah and even modern uh
academic non-muslim non academic sources
they are saying that when we look at the
Bible we can see different layers one of
them is called a Priestly Source where a
huge emphasis on priests and on their
position and we can see that this this
emphasis has been basically using the
religion for their own game so when
Jesus is saying it's not that the
Sabbath is not for man rather the master
the man is as the passage goes that the
Sabbath is
yeah but yeah it's it Jesus said it
basically so we can they pick from the
blood from the meat the wheat so what
happens is the
um these these rules they were made for
men okay it wasn't that the law uh is to
be used to be of Med and to and to
that's why the the the the Indonesia
mentions how they would have the best
best seats in the in the government yeah
yeah so this is the show off person is
close to God is meant to be the most
humbleists you're meant to have you're
meant to sit with the normal people
you're not meant to be this you're not
distinguish yourself that's why our
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him when
they enter Emissary from the Christians
came of najrang they came to see the
prophet they couldn't distinguish him
from the normal people
okay
entered upon the prophet Muhammad peace
upon him at this time he is the leader
of the Muslims in Medina
and he began to cry why he said look at
the kings of of Persia and the kings of
Rome and they have palaces and they have
these huge things that they have that
they have with them but yet you sleeping
on a bed of Breeze that's making it a
mock in your in your arm okay he began
to win that
similar to what Jesus says our kingdom
is not of this world Jesus said okay
I'm basically I am I'd rather be a
servant a prophet that is a servant then
a king okay a servant but humble it says
whoever humbles himself for God what
will raise him yeah don't raise your
soul yes okay and this is what Jesus is
referring to that kind of uh uh
self-pity self-pity right I have another
question
answer your questions yes yeah thank you
okay now
I right so I was as a Christian you
raised up with the concept of original
sin me personally I do not believe in
the concept of sin
I think described in Christianity what I
personally think this is me not any
other right I think that one an
individual can only cause a sin by doing
something
untowards or bad to his fellow human
beings this is what I think it upset God
since you know everybody it's a creation
of God right
every human being I would disagree with
that a little bit but why okay so yes
that's correct that is a sin but there's
also so this is the horizontal level yes
okay I take your watch I steal your
money I steal something like that I've
sinned against you but you've missed out
one thing which is the most important
that I could sit against the body as
well
God has given me my life right what is
giving my hearing my eyes my everything
but it's giving me so many blessings all
your faculties all my faculties and
everything else that I'm grateful for my
clothing my food my family everything
that I'm grateful for if we were to
enumerate uh the favors from God we
wouldn't be able to cannot enumerate
them there's no end here
and then to deny God and say you know
what God never did you know what I don't
care about it
this is the greatest crime
it's believing it's good okay so yes
you're right that sin is you can
transgress against somebody else against
your neighbor that is sin but the
greatest sin is to join the space
against God so you've got the horizontal
but the vertical you're missing so this
is this is so we say that God's right is
the greatest right right and that he
alone should be worshiped you can be put
to your parents good to your good man
good to everybody but yet the one who
created you you've never said Thank you
to him you've never acknowledged it
doesn't then you've actually you're not
actually a good person because the
greatest importance you ever give I'll
give you one example to understand your
mother I'm sure was a good woman looks
awesome
he was very passionate okay so you are
your your mother has looked off you yes
read you as a child all of your
education gave you your initial
nourishment okay you don't want to give
you an initial nourishment as a baby
then raise you after that and give it
and even now if you used to eat with
your mother your mother would make sure
that you eat before she eats absolutely
this is the mother okay now as you
imagine that as you became of age you
became a as a becoming man you never
went to visit I consider that the same
because the sin but that works you're
amazing everybody loves you at work with
all your work colleagues you're the best
guy you buy everybody gifts you buy
everybody's food lunch is on you all the
time are you a good man
if I ignore my mother yeah no I'm not
why because a greater priority you
haven't given it to to to where it's
great it's important you've done good to
others but the one where the the right
matters the most is how do people that
right now this will help you understand
that you could be good to everybody if
you're your mother
as well everybody but we've got this
great is you created your mother created
your children created everything you
have you haven't fulfilled his right so
this is why this is the greatest
Injustice this is why you can say this
person he was good to everybody but he
didn't believe him he didn't pray to God
the one who created him he didn't
acknowledge that this is the greatest
sin
think about it I'm I'm
so so my thinking goes like this I agree
with everything you said you agree yeah
yes yeah and thank you for the
explanation now moving on is
the universe
I'm I'm not quite sure but it's your
concept that I rather the universe is
not just the Earth right there are other
things out there
yeah of course yeah okay so I'm telling
you like this there's other creations
there is there is such a being as God
yeah right he created everything come
listen don't worry I'm not gonna blow up
throw it so so he created everything now
in this in the grand scheme of things of
the universe we are
you know it's pretty hard to explain how
little we are yeah it's such a big
exists and it created us here yeah don't
you find that very odd that
you will get offended by somebody so
small as we are so that's why I think
that he would rather if we are all his
creation yes you'd rather get offended
when we are terrible to each other
rather than how can you how can you harm
nobody can harm God never harmless at
all this is a concept I have a problem
two things with that yeah you cannot
is also insignificant that's the first
thing
but only significant it doesn't matter I
know insignificant in relation how
should I say as um so why would it be a
sin to harm somebody else but not a sin
to disbelieving God because
it doesn't conquer it doesn't harm God
at all
no no forget him
we we're talking about holidays
I just believe in God he's not gonna
hold me Society if you just believe in
God
we just foreign
and he has the characteristics of being
the most merciful then our most merciful
Creator who created all of us created
you you're also his creation he has
given he has enjoyed mercy upon the
whole of creation that's why there is
Mercy inside us the wife that's why the
mother has Mercy to her child that's why
the the cat has Mercy to his kittens why
because this is a mercy that God has
created a great place in the world okay
so this mercy of course he would he
would want a knowledgeable creator with
his mercy of course he would be bothered
or or or want us to deal good with each
other of course he would okay and also
with him that's the first point okay the
second point is when it comes to things
that are insignificant you see the leaf
on that tree yeah when that leaf force
does it follow an order
when the river goes down the side of the
mountain in a mountain in the middle of
nowhere there no one's watching it yeah
does it follow an order of course it
follows an order so everything has a
load that follows everything follows an
order okay so these things nobody's
going to sit there but yet they have an
order so now for us how can it be the
case that this all-knowing God who is
put inside us Mercy is put inside us
some knowledge and some uh kindness and
gentleness inside us also some anger and
some system he's given us these
attributes how can he not be bothered
about how we interact with each other
is
you you mentioned half of it but it did
uh sitting towards your person another
person yes it's not just that it's sin
towards God as well and we also differ
with uh agree with you against the
original sin is that sin is something
that must be I know that the like I know
the law and I turn away from it the baby
has no sin there's no such way there's
no way that the baby could have original
sin that he what is sin is to turn away
from God to go meaning you need to know
which way God's glory is and then turn
away from it so if the baby doesn't have
that faculty how can the baby then
inheritance
in the Christian religion the baby never
told Adam to eat the apple okay this is
a Christian concept but the baby was not
there present so the baby cannot now
Place have some of the same place from
him in order for him to be cleansed or
baptized what it is however as Islam
says that the children are born upon the
natural dispositions the children are
born pure with a clean slate and it is
their society that makes them become
accomplished
Allah
in the foreign
yeah so I don't know
um I I need to rephrase yeah says that
every child is born upon a natural state
however it is a society that makes him a
Jew a Christian or a major
so notice how we never said that society
makes them a Muslim
now the reason is so you say that let me
just give me a raise so we're on the
same page yeah originally you said
anything wrong here you said that a
child is born pure pure completely and
that would be pure as in sinless yes
Society takes them away from that
Natural State
going back to it if a child like Tarzan
born in the jungle yeah
so if he's upon that natural position
there's no Society to take him away from
that Natural State okay so he'll be upon
that naturally how would you know about
God if there's some someone like you
said I'll give you I'll give you an
example yeah and you can see this in
history every society in history okay
maybe exception about one percent but if
you used to look at the history as a
whole every society they have a concept
of a supreme god that created everything
okay but then they also have local
deities okay yeah okay it is my
ancestors was a righteous man he must be
holy so we're gonna worship him oh the
sun Worship in the sun Worship in the
moon so every society they have this
Creator God but then they have little
local deities to get to that one okay so
it's either one or two things Eva
mankind all started with these local
deities and they became they they worked
out to get to that one good yeah and
they came to conclusion all of the
University but you know what they must
be that that was the start point and
then they deviated from that to these
little over these things you'll see that
the case of mankind
but you can see
that start quick every society is that
they have this natural belief in a uh
one single Supreme Being A Creator
that's why if you go to China ancient
China yeah 2000 BC you see they have a a
song called to the emperor of the sky
it was some people is the sky above the
thing about
in in West Africa they had a a a good
good young Kim pong the god of the sky
okay in in the Middle East they had El
Allah this guy this God that was uh
separate and distinct from inspiration
the word guts comes from the ancient
Germanic word for God when God comes to
the ancient word gut meaning the supreme
god this was Universal across all the
world so the thing about Tarzan for
example the question in Amazon rainfall
it's possible that that could happen
yeah yeah a person could be isolated
yeah in him he would know and understand
about a natural uh uh this Creator
naturally he would know about this yeah
okay all right but in my understanding
because I have someone
so on the day of judgment
there will be those who receive them
and turned away from me
those who received
the message
and those who have not received the
message okay for those people is
an example he would have been someone I
didn't hear the message yes
yes exactly so he would have his test on
the day of judgment so Eva the message
was given to him in a corrupted form so
what is Islam Islam they worship
or Islam they worship okay for a
thousand years in Christianity Inferno
is that the main kind of media was plays
and songs and Poets and so on and so
forth and composers who are Christians
actually don't feel safe because they
believe that Muslims pray to an idol in
the desert yeah in Mecca okay which is
the black side the Black song okay
um so so if the message has come to
those people in a corrupted form or any
people is coming to corrupted form but
if it hasn't been presented at all these
people are known as and they will have
their tests on the day of judgment so so
can I ask you is this something
say for example
do you have children yeah yeah
it's the same right that would be no no
no but what do you consider so so
Sinister basically is that which is this
reason to Allah
okay but from the faculties
when a person is considered to be sinful
is when they have the faculties of
comprehension okay okay does the person
who has a fit when he's he's got
epilepsy and he has a fit when he's
sleeping and he rolls over and hits his
wife in the face okay is that a sin is
this
for the food
is your wife yeah
why because it's a faculty has to come
with the intention and how do you apply
that to the situation with the children
so the children they don't have the
faculty
but what Islam is it's not okay they're
not born with short um what Islam is is
a continuation of that Faith they still
need guidance people will not be judged
based upon that pure message alone it's
not about just having the pure message
and the the sound intellect also Allah
sends Messengers okay this is what a
person can be judged when they rejected
the message not when they rejected their
Fitters or their their natural
disposition or they reject their
intellects that's not enough to put them
in health well it's when the message
comes to them that's in line with that
physical
and in line with that intellect and in
line with the previous property that
message that comes and you turn away
from that that's when you can say that
you had a water that came through and
you understood it it wasn't like in when
they went to Cuba when the Spanish went
to Cuba to give the Supreme Christianity
they were reciting
and Spanish uh uh what the Bible about
craving Christ is the Lord the Cubans
the current people that were living
there they didn't understand Spanish
what happened they slaughtered them yeah
establishing the proof they have to
understand it has to resonate with them
and then turn away from it are you a
logical thinker I'm a logical thinking
that's right you try it yeah and like
like that Islam is more for something
that you can think of logically
understand logically right so we say in
Islam that Islam the the intellect has a
position in Islam and that position is
not the whole of Islam we say that the
intellect is like a witness that is
brought into a court case I understand
okay and the Sharia the actual
Revelation this is the judge so when the
the judge needs the witness to bring
forth his testimony he pulls them
forward but when the judge is in no need
of his testimony he dismisses it so just
just a
um
when it comes to understanding good okay
there's some things that are going to be
beyond our comprehension about God not
against our comprehension okay there's a
difference between beyond our
comprehension and against our convention
okay if I was to say to you about
looking my shoe size is size nine
what is that is that in line with your
knowledge me my name is Anwar my shoe
size is size nine is that beyond your
knowledge or or against your knowledge
well I don't know
I'm sorry yeah what's your name James
I'm gonna give another statement okay
now you tell me if it's beyond already
because James's suit shoe size is size
eight in my mother's yeah yeah that's in
your knowledge okay so that's the
difference okay now when it comes to
believe in in Allah there are some
things that are beyond our knowledge
even say me or one of our Scholars
mentioned that Islam comes with that
which amazes the mind not which which um
so uh when it comes to increased to us
how many leaves on from those three
trees here how many leaves are there
how many leaves are there exactly
exactly okay how many hairs on your head
exactly so this is the creation so there
are going to be some things that are
beyond our knowledge with bus 2 to
Creator okay so when it comes to are we
intellectual people yeah we try to be
intellectual but we and unless other
people that came into these literally
um that we understand the limits of the
internet and we don't try to apply the
limit of the intellect in a position
that is not made for
okay so so going back to the original
flavor because I just want to just give
you yeah my belief yeah because of the
way that I think about it it's really
logical and it makes and it makes sense
now you say that a child is more pure
yeah yeah see I I kind of have the the
opposite belief that we're born into
iniquity based on things that have
happened for our ancestry all of our
ancestry we made it all the way back to
the original Adam the original sin yeah
um and the reason why I think that
because if I hit yours and I'm a guy
that likes the logic and think things
look at it and work it out I'm not
someone that just believes something
like that okay and the reason why I
think about it you're a father yeah
and like growing up
and protective yeah
um when he was growing up there was
times where I'd say to him at a young
age and I'm sure as a parent and all the
parents they can say this as well
foreign
that this light is clean okay inside the
nature of Man Poor Man we have the
ability to write and that we need to do
wrong okay that's cool
is basically what distinguishes us from
the Angels the Angels they they just on
paper we can choose to obey God and
choose to disobey but we have choice
this is why we held to be held to
account
the baby that is crying okay the baby
that is crying I'm talking about the
newborn that is crying and you tell him
stop crying that's different why is it
different because they're crying out for
a need okay but I told them I don't want
him to cry obey him
because I can come up to you and be like
yo my friend can have a drink of water
please where a baby can't say I want to
drink a water because they need to cry
out and that's their way of doing it
yeah they can't they can't speak
I'm trying to if a person was that
sadistic to say to the baby I'm gonna
make you strong why is it different I
know it's different of course because
I'm dead
Desiring to be Disobedience where if you
say don't do
don't do that you know doing that is
what you've asked them not to do but
don't crying out for anything but you
agree that from from a point or point of
a baby to somewhere uh to adulthood
that that kind of understanding of right
or wrong uh develops okay and then a
person at a certain age they have a firm
understanding so what we're saying but
there was always a conscience consistent
well even at the baby but that's kind of
off the road even even a newborn
even a newborn what are we asking again
the newborn that I said for example okay
let's say let's say a one-year-old
one-year-old is not like a newborn
you told me about and I told you about
the Garden or the universe and all of
that now with regards to the original
sin yeah and why I I know this is the
I'm a Christian by the way yes so yeah
so that's I don't believe in it because
the way you described in the Bible
so before I was described in the Bible
they didn't know you know what is right
and what is wrong or they maybe I don't
know I don't even know they Myself Away
now I think there is an innate
in the studio
come back in it if you wanna and those
possible questions okay every Friday
yeah
no this one same page okay same page
let's put the US Dollar on YouTube
is
yeah
what should I say they don't become
aware as
in the Bible it says okay
because he was no longer naked but he
covered himself yeah he was a shame yeah
and that according to the Bible because
he becomes basically self-aware right
you know until then he why was he not
change in the 48 from the house he
recognizes nakedness I put into the
physical narrative right now
is
I don't think you send that to scrutiny
because like I told you you take
somebody from crazy and he grows up but
never seen anybody dressed up he doesn't
need them
it's not cold it's warm so you don't
have to dress up right okay and you
don't have to so they will never what
I'm trying to say to you they will never
realize that they are native
because they've never been naked
because they're always naked
okay yes yeah yeah so what I'm saying is
that somebody can grow up like you said
just now you know without hearing the
word of God so somebody
from birth all the way to adulthood they
can grow up somewhere
if the conditions are right without
realizing that they are next or the need
to cover up it's not what do you mean
specifically the needs that actually
actually laws on dress code yes exactly
like it's in your Bible that because
well
so so
this is
for me why why this is this is this is
uh basically up movement okay we live in
society we live amongst each other okay
yes we're talking about the hypothetical
situation yeah in the rare cases where
people live by themselves as I mentioned
to the to the to my friend here that
um
on the day of judgment these two will
have their own tests okay as for us it's
when the Revelation comes the Revelation
comes how do we interact with that
Revelation do we ponder over it reflect
over it and that if we come to the
conclusion it's from God we follow it
sincerely or do we become arrogant stick
with what our forefathers were upon and
still stick with what is what is trendy
or whatever whatever the fashion is at
the time or if you humble ourselves so
for God and go against the great so this
is we're going to be how to account by
how we interact with Revelation the
Revelation that kind of lost
that when when this Revelation that
makes sense to you that you have one God
worship him alone these are the messages
of the Prophet this is the message of
the last of them in line with those
previous messages for you to worship God
Alone follow his example
we will be held accountable
nope the people in the Hellfire these
the caliber of these people the tribal
people that these are these are the
people that if they will put out of hell
they would go back to this disbelieve
again they are pure pure going against
uh the great however these people will
be us did not want to come to you did a
messenger come to you right and they
said they would admit yes
so as for the hypothetical situations
that doesn't help us enough to another
Square no I know I know I know that was
just with regards to the original yeah
right but what you can do what you can
do because unlike most people or a lot
of people in this decided maybe even
more I don't know uh actually it's most
now because they've done the study most
people are non-religious uh uh don't
believe in the crate type I'm not sure
if it's atheistic I'm going to say maybe
I could but we have something in common
we have an understanding of this Creator
are you coming from a like a Christian
background you have an understanding of
this the the profits and messages in
your scripture that created this one so
you can do this now you can turn it into
yourself Jesus of Abraham a lot of paper
happened ask him to guide you to the
truth wherever it is
May the god of Abraham it was neither
dream nor Christian what religion was he
thank you
other religious religion is basically uh
we had a religion religion is basically
what your heart is that's what it means
religion religion to time okay so what
is hard to tie to was submission so what
this was his talk
submitting to God Alone following
whatever he wherever goes come on then
he would follow them if he said go right
go right go back go back for food go
forward he would follow good come on
this this is what uh submission is what
Islam means
so this is the relation of Abraham he
pre-existed Christianity he pre-existed
Judaism okay
in fact today is the subscribe to Judah
which is the son of one of his latest
Sons okay so this word of Abraham may he
guide us through the truth whatever it
is reflect upon this when you go home
when you're alone when nobody's looking
up at you and you're secluded
that this
is the final Revelation and this is from
Allah
then it's upon you to follow that and
act in a few days
do you think that he ain't the world
through human right he gives messages
and he has prophets and messages as a
Christian or from a Christian background
you listen to yes
and that refer back to my discussion
with regards to the universe and the God
and the concept of sin here right with
quiet my belief my
because okay I believe in a Creator
right but I don't think I honestly think
that that's not enough and it shouldn't
be enough to go to heaven is creators
oh I do worshipers you think they don't
believe in the prayer
do you believe that this Creator created
you how do you react to that it's about
worship women alone yes you can believe
there's a creator that exists
yeah
prophets and messages came with they
never came Islam doesn't come to tell
you that you know
you would see that he says I am the best
amongst you to my wives the wife is not
Allah so you see me how to be good to
your wives this is the best if you are
the best of goods those who the best
said he said the believer doesn't go to
sleep while his neighbor is starving
okay so the belief what is the lowest of
faith in Islam is to remove something
awful from the road
the lowest of faith in Islam right still
encourage them to do it as action is to
remove something off on the road who
walks on the road it's not just me
everybody so in a society the Muslim has
a huge impact the practice in Muslim we
have Muslims by name and they're the
Muslims but when a Muslim really acts
upon his religion you'll see a big
difference
How can there be people going to
feedback subscribing in London when
there's Muslims everywhere if the
Muslims want to follow small
Commandments of the Prophet Muhammad
peace he said for example when you make
a soup add water so you could feed the
neighbor and the neighbor is 40 that way
and 40 that way if you live in a flat 40
I'll put it down how can we see people
that are starving exactly in London when
we have to follow it it's not that it's
not there because we're not following it
so if you follow it correctly you'll see
that the stamp gives everything
established the the balances with
Justice meaning it gives rights first
and foremost to Allah then to the people
and all around in fact it even gives
rats to your own body
your body has rights over you meaning
that when it's time to rest take your
rest
take the the mid midday not because so
it gives right to your body it gives
rights to your neighbors but most
importantly and your family and your
yourself is also most importantly the
right of your creator
that associate partners with Allah is
the greatest oppression so associate
partners of God he created you alone but
yet you're going to give thanks to
somebody else worship Him worship
something else to get to Allah this is
the greatest oppression okay so it puts
everything in his right place and this
is wisdom so this is Islam and if you
know where to reflect a contact message
I've prayed to that God that you know
instinctively I'm not telling you about
a God you never heard of but you never
knew the one you already know asking for
guidance and you'll see that you had no
reflect over the Quran and you will see
that it will guide you to the truth and
you will see that is from him when you
use your sound Petra and you'll sound
reasoning and reflect or ponder over
this book and you will see that this is
from the the same Creator who gave your
natural inclination you gave your eyes
your brain your your heart to
contemplate them this this crazy
compatible with what I said before yeah
concerning our neighbors so much so that
we thought that they would inherit from
us after we die
foreign
we see this a lot in Muslim countries
all the aunties the Muslim aunties that
live in London that feed their neighbors
because we see this a lot a lot of uh
the Moroccan aunties they make Herrera
and they give it to the to the neighbors
we see Somalian artists so if you're
really living next door you want to know
if you're living next to a good Muslim
does he feed you does he help you
so you'll see you'll see that the
emphasis on the neighbors and the
society that we live in and the rights
of the people is Islam has a huge
emphasis on this I'm not allowed to
cheat at all I'm not allowed to take
interest from people I'm not allowed to
to harm you I'm not allowed to sell
alcohol how many Muslim shops you see
that they say awful
alcohol I know alcohol harmsy so I'm
allowed to sell it even to you
even if I'm gonna make money off it so
this is
looking for us but anyway you've
understood what I'm saying yes can I
give you some literature yes yeah